bonjour à toutes et à tous
comme a dit rémy je m'appelle niveau da
silva j'ai 31 ans je suis étudiant en
journalisme à l'iec ce qui est une école
bruxelloise et dans le cadre de la
réalisation d'un mémoire médiatique mon
équipe et moi même nous sommes
intéressés à la prison du futur alors en
fait l'idée c'est un nouveau système
carcéral en belgique qui va peut-être
révolutionner un peu le milieu de la
prison
alors si on a choisi ce thème c'est
parce qu'on a remarqué c'est serait en
partie d'un constat assez simple c'est
qu'on a remarqué que la prison classique
comme on la connaît depuis très
longtemps eh bien elle ne fonctionne pas
ou qu'elle fonctionne mal parfois même
elle crée de nouveaux problèmes mais
avant de vous en parler dans le détail
des maisons de détention je vais vous
demander juste de prendre un instant
pour réfléchir
un instant pour vous demander si vous
accepteriez ou non que la prison du
futur se trouve à côté de chez vous et
que les détenus pourraient sortir
occasionnellement en journée pour
travailler pour suivre une formation
suivre une thérapie
alors prenez bien le temps d'y réfléchir
et soyez bien sûr honnête avec vous-même
est ce que vous trouvez l'idée farfelue
voire dangereuse
pensez vous que les personnes qui sont
incarcérés et qui ont donc commis des
fautes doivent l'être
7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur 24 ou au
contraire accepteriez-vous de leur
laisser davantage de liberté à condition
peut-être que ces personnes ne se trouve
pas à côté de chez vous alors je vous
rassure tout de suite il n'y a
évidemment pas de bonnes ou de mauvaises
réponses à ces questions toutes vos
réponses sont légitimes ce sont des
questions importantes délicate qui font
écho à de grands principes qui
structurent nos sociétés depuis pas mal
de temps
la liberté la sécurité la dignité
humaine et bien sûr l'espoir
la belgique a décidé aujourd'hui de
parier sur une nouvelle façon
d'incarcérer et de traiter les détenus
c'est sans aucun doute parce que le
système carcéral actuelle n'est pas
assez efficace
en france prenons l'exemple de la france
là sur la surpopulation pardon carcéral
elle est chronique ça veut donc dire
qu'il n'ya pas assez de places de prison
opérationnelle par rapport au nombre de
détenus et ce depuis très longtemps
alors fin 2021 les prisons françaises le
taux d'occupation dans les prisons
françaises
était de 115 4 % ce qui est évidemment
beaucoup trop dans certaines prisons
françaises comme par exemple les maisons
d'arrêt à nîmes ou encore ici un juste à
côté de bordeaux à gradignan il me
semble
ce taux d'occupation il dépasse les 200
%
c'est juste énorme on sera d'accord
alors en belgique moi qui viens de
belgique chez moi c'est pareil c'est à
dire que le taux d'occupation moyen dans
les prisons idée de
120,6 % toujours trop mais alors ça
c'est des chiffres on est d'accord c'est
hyper théorique soudaine de chiffres on
voit mais concrètement qu'est ce que ça
donne dans la vie des gens bien
concrètement ça donne des gardiens au
bout enfin très en colère concrètement
ça donne des détenus qui dorment parfois
sur des matelas au sol à quatre ou cinq
dans des cellules de deux ça provoque
donc la colère des gardiens je les dis
mais aussi des familles des prisonniers
des psychologues de prison parfois les
prisons sont même vétustes et on parle
bien de la france et de la belgique là
je sais pas si on se rend bien compte
que la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a condamné la belgique et la
france pour mauvaise gestion de mauvais
traitements vis-à-vis de ces prisonniers
de leurs prisonniers alors honnêtement
ça c'est que mon point de vue je trouve
ça plutôt gênant pour des pays comme la
france et la belgique qui sont censés
être leader en matière de respect de la
dignité humaine
raison pour laquelle donc
la belgique a créé de nouvelles maisons
de détention
je vous en parle dans le détail dans le
détail pardon dans quelques secondes ce
que je veux vous dire aussi c'est que
outre les problèmes dans le quotidien
des prisonniers ça c'est du court terme
c'est du présent il faut voir à l'avenir
ce que ça provoque ce que ses conditions
de détention de provoc et bien la
récidive la récidive est encore la
récidive alors en france
près d'un ex-détenu sur trois donc près
de 30 % des détenus récidive dans
l'année de la sortie de saint john dans
l'année de sortie de prison pardon en
belgique ce n'est pas beaucoup mieux
c'est même pire dans 57% des cas
l'auteur l'ex-détenu récidive une
nouvelle fois alors c'est juste énorme
évidemment ces maisons de détention sont
donc porteuse d'espoir
les maisons des tensions elles
accueilleront que entre 20 et 60 détenus
ce qui est vraiment peu
pendant la journée les détenus pourront
donc sortir je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
afin de suivre des formations suivre des
thérapies voir leur famille et même
travailler l'objectif il est simple
c'est de ne pas trop les couper de la
société de leur laisser une certaine
liberté de mouvement et un certain droit
aux contacts sociaux l'emplacement des
maisons de détention s'il est très
important puisque en fait l'idée si ça
fonctionne bien sûr c'est les premières
maisons détention fonctionne c'est d'en
avoir un peu partout sur le territoire
belge et pourquoi pas un jour sur le
territoire français pour que les détenus
soient proches de leur famille afin de
toujours garder ce contact social
en revanche ce ne seront pas tous les
détenus enfin toutes les personnes
condamnées n'iront pas dans ces centres
dans ces maisons de détention mais
uniquement les personnes qui ont commis
qui ont qu'une peine pardon de moins de
3 ans d'emprisonnement il n'y aura donc
pas de violeurs de terroristes ou de
délinquants trop violent
alors théoriquement on est d'accord ça a
l'air génial vraiment théoriquement
c'est un bon pas voilà un pas dans la
bonne direction mais ça c'est théorique
parce que bien sûr cela soulève des
questions pas mal de questions et en
particulier une contradiction majeure
les personnes qui vont être enfermés
dans ces maisons de détention jusqu'ici
elle n'était pas enfermée elle
bénéficier de sursis ou d'un bracelet
électronique ce qui veut donc dire que
la désormais elles seront incarcérés je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de la
surpopulation carcérale alors on peut
bien sûr se demander si ouvrir de
nouvelles maisons de détention
est une bonne idée quand on voit déjà la
détresse et le nombre de personnes qui
sont incarcérés mais les maisons de
détention il faut pas les
en fait il faut essayer de prendre du
recul de prendre de la hauteur de
regarder à long terme je voulais dit
tout à l'heure on veut lutter contre la
récidive c'est donc pour ça que les
maisons de détention vont être en
belgique et elles seront alors plus
contraignantes que le bracelet
électronique ou bien évidemment que le
sursis mais moins contraignante que les
prisons c'est donc sur cet équilibre sur
ce compromis que souhaite parier l'état
belge
une grande question n'a eu de cesse de
traverser la philosophie depuis des
siècles comment donner du sens à la
peine
comment punir un délit à sa juste mesure
comment punir un crime à sa juste mesure
et où placer le curseur entre d'une part
ses vérités et intransigeance et d'autre
part en pâtit et dignité humaine bien
sûr alors ça c'est le grand défi de la
justice moi je n'ai évidemment pas les
réponses mais ce qui est très frappant
c'est que depuis platon a aujourd'hui le
sens de la pm le sens qu'on a donné à la
peine a toujours été celui de la prison
de l'enfermement
socrates par exemple questionner déjà le
fait d'être puni sans pour autant être
contre la prison tandis qu'aristote lui
s'interrogeait sur la juste mesure qu'il
ya entre la faute et la peine
un autre penseur michel foucault plus
contemporain a écrit en 1975 où 75
pardon comme on dit en france dans
surveiller ou punir une réflexion très
intéressante sur la prison et c'est
alors poser les questions suivantes
peut-on punir sans peine prenez bien
temps de réfléchir peut-on punir sans
peine
peut-on punir un délit ou un crime sans
incarcération
et faut-il faire souffrir celui qui a
fait souffrir celui ou celle qui a fait
souffrir pour que justice soit rendue
que la faute soit expier corrigé voire
même pardonné
une nouvelle fois ce n'est pas les
réponses à ça
mais ce que je retiens précisément de ce
qu'a écrit michel foucault c'est que
selon lui l'ex n est pas nécessaire bien
au contraire
l'objectif il est celui de la plus
grande économie du système pénal
c'est là le sens de l'humanité alors ce
qui est véritablement important en effet
dans la nouvelle réalité sociale ce
n'est pas l'exemplarité de la peine non
c'est son efficacité
et c'est donc le rôle des maisons
détention leur but c'est la recherche de
l'efficacité en laissant donc un certain
nombre de libertés aux détenus
je sais que c'est difficile d'imaginer
en tout cas je vois là que c'est
difficile pour vous de vous sentir
impliqué de vous sentir concernés par la
problématique que sont les prisons on a
chacun une vie on a chacun des problèmes
en à chacun des joies des peines
est l'objectif de ces maisons de
détention et de sanctionner les
délinquants tout en leur apportant de
l'aide voir mais je vais même plus loin
en leur apportant de l'espoir et
l'espoir c'est précisément ce qu'il
manque à beaucoup de gens à toutes ces
personnes qui commettent des crimes qui
commettent des délits qui n'ont
peut-être pas eu la même source que vous
et moi d'avoir des parents aimants une
éducation solide ou un environnement
social sain
nous sommes toutes et tous en constante
évolution en constante croissance selon
le philosophe anglophone allan watt nous
avons parfaitement le droit de ne pas
être la personne que nous étions il ya
cinq minutes non nous avons ce droit là
notre choix est de savoir si l'on
préfère être une meilleure personne ou
une moins bonne personne et c'est
précisément l'espoir qui fait que ce que
nous avons envie d'être meilleur hier
vous aujourd'hui pardon d'être meilleur
demain pierre que du coup s'annonce pas
trop cela
alors l'espoir c'est un grand mot mais
l'espoir c'est vraiment le but moi je
vais être honnête avec vous je ne sais
pas si ces maisons de détention devront
fonctionner je n'en sais rien il va
falloir du temps pour tirer un bilan des
semaines des années des décennies pour
savoir si elles sont efficaces ou non
mais au moins nous essayons et c'est ça
la clé nous essayons ça fait des
dizaines d'années voire des siècles que
la prison fait souffrir les gardiens le
personnel est prisonnier la famille tout
le monde alors il est temps que ça
change
donc si ça ne marche pas cette fois ci
tant pis si les prisons c'est les
maisons des tensions pardon ne sont pas
efficaces tant pis au moins nous
essayons
alors je ne dirai qu'une chose ayant de
l'espoir
ayant de l'espoir pour les prisonniers
pour leur famille pour les gardiens
ayant l'espoir pour vous pour moi et
pour nous tous
merci
[Applaudissements]